the more I read about the gulags system
in the USSR and what happened in China
and what happened in Nazi Germany the
more it became evident to me that these
weren't top-down systems imposed by
tyrants on an unwilling innocent
population but decisions on the part of
entire cultures to go down a certain
Road often the leaders were following
which I would say was particularly the
case with Hitler which isn't to deny him
his criminal culpability but Hitler was
unbelievably good at letting the crowd
tell him what to say you know he was a
he was a mirror for the crowd and he was
a good orator but he paid attention to
the crowd and so when he said something
that made everyone sheer you know their
dark hearts would come out in the mob
and cheer about something he said that
was say dramatic room or vengeful well
then he'd say more of that and the
things that he said that were peaceful
that produced no emotional reaction from
the crowd he just said less of and so
the crowd taught him over time exactly
what to sell them and not that can be
good in some sense if a leader does that
carefully that
that means he's integrating what the
crowd wants with his style of leadership
but it can be terrible if the mob is the
crowd and the mob is outraged and out
for blood and that's what happened in
Nazi Germany and so you can't blame it
on Hitler that's just not reasonable
it's distributed through the entire
population and it's a the individual
level of analysis that's most
significant